in september the new york times
published a story showing that president
donald trump
only paid 750 in federal income taxes
in 2016 and 2017 respectively
this shocking total led many people to
ask so
is donald trump actually rich the answer
is most definitely
yes he is still a billionaire donald
trump does owe a tremendous amount of
money if you add it all
up it's about 1.1 billion dollars which
is a ton of money to owe even if you're
really rich
but he also has an enormous amount of
assets calculating net worth is
actually a pretty simple equation you
subtract the person's debt
from their assets if you tally all of
those up they get to 3.66 billion
dollars
so it's just subtraction from there 3.66
minus 1.1
his net worth right now is two and a
half billion dollars
the real trouble is how to value the
different assets a person has
there are different ways of valuing say
real estate versus the value of shares
in a company someone holds
in trump's case much of his value is
held in the property that he owns
and a key way of finding out the value
of commercial real estate is to look at
net operating income
or how profitable the real estate is
so for example if you look at 40 wall
street which is trump's skyscraper down
in the financial district in new york
so the net operating income of that
building is about 18.1 million dollars
so you take that 18.1 million dollars
and then what we do to figure out the
values we call up a bunch of people who
buy and sell
real estate new york city all day long
all year long
so for this particular example you know
we called up eight different people
and we asked those people now what's the
multiple
that you might expect for a building
like this
on that profitability to then determine
what the value
is and they come up with
you know slightly different numbers so
you get a range they were suggesting
that the net operating income should be
about 5.4 percent
of the total value of the building now
if you do the math on that with
18.1 million dollars and that suggests
that the value of the building
should be about 366 million dollars
but that's not the only way of looking
at a building's value
you can also look at the cost per square
foot
let's look at dan's example of 40 wall
street that building is about 1.165
million square feet going around to
experts again
the average response of how much a
building like that would be worth
was around 400 per square foot
this puts 40 wall street at a value of
million dollars a different number than
when we calculated the cost
using net operating income and here's
where it gets to be a little bit of an
art in addition to the science and math
of it and you have to figure out well
how are we going to blend those things
together
and in this case one of those
methodologies isn't clearly right or
wrong they just come to slightly
different numbers
and so what we chose to do here is to
just
average them and so that means that the
estimated value of that building
is 401 million dollars if you march
through trump's portfolio
and you look at all of his buildings his
golf courses you can add all of that
up and then you get the total value of
all of his assets
if you go through everything that total
value adds up to about 3.66 billion
dollars
so trump really is wealthy but how do
you get away with paying only 750
in income taxes the answer lies in the
difference between net
operating income and taxable income or
how much income an individual declares
is taxable after a number of deductions
for example it calculates how much
interest
you're paying on that property and so
you would subtract that from the
net operating income so if you have a
lot of debt against the property
then all of a sudden your net operating
income shrinks a lot if you have
invested a bunch of money into a
particular property
then that would then shrink what your
income would be from that net operating
income
getting closer down to the taxable
income there are also more aggressive
accounting tricks one can play to
decrease what they owe
for instance it looks like ivanka trump
was both serving as an employee of the
trump organization
while also collecting consulting fees
from the trump organization and that
would allow them donald trump to
write off those consulting fees and
therefore make his
taxable income look even smaller so
every business person
is going to take a net operating income
and
shrink it down for their taxable income
what was so astonishing about this
report
is just the the level uh that it
happened
and the fact that these are enormous
operating profits across trump's
portfolio and they're real profits we
can see it
it's documented in sec documents i mean
1290 avenue in the americas trump owns a
stake in that that 30 stake alone is
generating more than 20 million dollars
from that operating income per year
same with 555 california street in san
francisco
40 wall street in downtown new york 18.1
million dollars of net operating income
per year trump tower in new york city
more than 13 million
net operating income per year so that's
real real money and yes he's got a lot
of debt much of which is
is coming due but he does have a way out
here
but it's going to require some moves
that would be typical for a normal
businessman
but present serious conflicts of
interest for the president of the united
states
one option is that he goes on to wall
street and asks banks that his
administration is regulating and
investigating
for hundreds of millions of dollars
another option is that he sells off
very valuable assets and then welcomes
anybody who wants
to put hundreds of millions of dollars
into his personal portfolio
neither of those things again would be
unusual for a standard businessman
but nothing about doing business with
the president of the united states
is standard and so then you run into
large questions about conflicts of
interest